[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga we
broadcast as the Munich Security
Conference gets underway at what the
conference's Chairman is referring to as
an historical inflection point the most
volatile period in his view since the
Second World War and a key aspect of
that volatility is new doubt about the
US commitment to the international
security order how to interpret
president Trump's America first policy
was a key issue as NATO defence
ministers met this week in Brussels
many Europeans fear the US could be
preparing to turn its back on its
traditional NATO allies and that
Washington's policy could play into the
hands of Russian President Putin and
wind up inadvertently benefiting China
America first a threat to the world
order that's the question posed by our
title this week and we're going to pose
it to three guests who've been following
subject very closely
Matthew kinetic is the chief
correspondent for the European issue of
Politico and he says Europe is too weak
and divided to fend for itself it should
do everything it can to safeguard the
relationship with Washington shaming is
a journalist from Beijing who has lived
in Berlin for some years he says there
won't be any clear-cut showdown between
China and the US over the Pacific region
instead we'll see countless agonizing
quarrels and mottle aiming is with us
once again it's a senior opinion editor
at the Tongass Spiegel the German
newspaper he says it is still not clear
what Trump's foreign policy priorities
are
but strengthening NATO and committing
the US president to the rule of law are
the best strategies for now so Matthew
Cooney to Nick a president Trump has now
been in office just about four weeks for
very tumultuous weeks in that amount of
time he has offended long-term us
friends like Australia neighbors like
Mexico he has issued ominous warnings to
Iran and China and made highly
contradictory pronouncements on Russia
and Israel so how do you read these
signals and how much do you think the
new US government does in fact
an outright disruption to the
international order well I think there
definitely is a disruption the question
is what will this mean in the long term
for the USS relationship with Europe and
with other countries and and for the
world order and we don't really know
right now there's certainly a sense of
drift there going to be
investigations now in the US it sounds
like into the new administration's ties
to Russia that could make it more
difficult for Trump to try and forge
some kind of new arrangement with
Vladimir Putin to try and take China
which is something that he clearly had
planned to do before he came into office
so the events as you sketched out are
just kind of you know moving so fast
that it's very difficult to to say what
is going to happen and and what the
policy is going to be especially when it
comes to issues like NATO when it comes
to issues like China and terrorism and
so on let's nonetheless try to read a
few tea leaves Multi lemming you also
said very mixed signals that we have
been hearing they shift from day to day
perhaps in no small be a small part
because Donald Trump apparently likes to
have competing centers of power around
him and purposefully set up his cabinets
cabinet and advisors that way so tell me
the resignation of the National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn accused of overly
close contact with Russia does that
perhaps represent the waning of that
particular power center of the rather
unconventional pro-russian group I wish
I could be more precise and and
straightforward than the Matthew is but
it's so hard to to interpret all these
mixed signals and I'm afraid maybe maybe
Donald Trump has different power centers
in himself because is he does he wants
to have a good new relationship Putin
the one really knows good relationship
with China nobody really knows does he
see in favor or against a two-state
solution nobody really knows there's so
many conflicting not just conflicting
but contradictory elements in his
rhetoric that it's very hard to predict
his his his motivations and out
he certainly wants to provoke the what
he's calling the establishment still he
did that and his election campaign and
he's still doing this as a president
with his tweets with his rhetoric with
all these things but I think this is due
to to to his desire to please his
constituency or what it believes to be
his constituency because this was the
main motivations for many Americans to
vote for him so this is still the in the
in the face of his presidency when he
still wants to provoke not sending a
clear coherent foreign policy agenda
what is your take and what are you
hearing from sources in China about the
various revelations that we've heard
about close contacts between Russia and
not only Michael Flynn the National
Security Advisor who stepped down but
apparently also other members of Donald
Trump's close team what's what's your
interpretation of that I think on the
one hand Chinese government shows a
little bit like this happiness that this
American government does not prove as
strong as it should be we are glad to
see that Donald Trump is facing more
difficulties as he would like to show
but on the other hand a quite unpleasant
feeling is now upcoming because this
issue with the Security Council shows
that Donald Trump is looking for secret
connections over business and there are
so many Chinese businessman business
women looking for connections with the
AU the secret councils or high ranking
officers around Trump maybe in some time
soon
there were being another affair but this
time not because of unpleasant ties to
Russia but because of unpleasant ties to
China
I think the Chinese Apollo politic are
somehow bothered with such kind of news
it is not clear that we all are glad to
see and we are not sure whether Trump is
going to get even hotter even tougher
because of this a difficulties he could
distract even more attention if he
succeeded in making China convincingly
to his main enemy I want to come back to
that point a bit later but the idea that
we just heard from XI Ming that the very
business-oriented nature of mr. Trump's
view of the world
Matthew Carney tunic that that could
actually make his administration
vulnerable to extortion to corruption is
that also one of the security risks in
fact that this Trump the the new
government entails absolutely and I
think that you've also seen that in
recent days just the way that he deals
with people would he what he deals with
the way he deals with foreign visitors
when the Japanese Prime Minister Abe a
was visiting him at his sort of weekend
residence in Florida and they were
discussing North Korea and then it
turned out that they were sort of
looking at documents secret documents
with the flashlight of a mobile phone
you know this outdoor restaurant were
there all kinds of guests and there was
a wedding party going on and all this
stuff going on it's clearly somebody who
is not you know comfortable in dealing
in sort of the usual confines of
government and and that is definitely a
danger to national security in in the
long term and I I think you know the the
other tendency that we've seen since
Trump came into office is that that we
in the press are always trying to kind
of figure out what the actual plan is
behind this as you said they're well
they're these power centers and you like
to play people off a little bit like
Abraham Lincoln you know the sort of
team of rivals idea first time I've
heard Donald
I think that there really isn't any
method to the madness there there is
just there is just madness and it comes
out in the tweets this is another thing
with people you know that former US
ambassador to Germany said during his
farewell speech he said oh don't pay
attention to the tweets this is just
part of his strategy to distract people
from things he doesn't want you to talk
about and I'm not really sure that's the
case anymore
the big danger I would say I mean the
big question right now is what is the
what is the greatest danger is that a
more or less dysfunctional chaotic
Washington White House system which
scandals almost every day which is so
weak that this cannot implement his
policy is that a bigger danger than a
functional White House which could
implement a maybe policy that we don't
like so what in in security terms this
is right now the the alternative we have
to face and it's very very hard question
to answer and I think that's exactly
what a lot of his opponents are opening
is that these scandals will weaken his
administration so much that it becomes
paralyzed that they're just dealing with
all of these internal scandals and
defending themselves and but there is a
danger coming out of a paralyzed
dysfunctional White House and washing
absolutely let me take us back to the
issue raised in the very first report
that we saw in our program namely
security policy because in fact we do
meet as that Munich Security Council a
conference is getting underway its title
this year is post truth post West
post-order and on the way to Munich the
new US defense minister appeared to
defend the current order at least in
part as he met with his NATO
counterparts the alliance remains a
fundamental bedrock for the United
States and for all the transatlantic
community bonded as we are together as
president Trump has stated he has strong
support for NATO it's a fair demand that
all who benefit from the best defense in
the world carry their proportionate
share of the necessary cost to defend
freedom
so I want to ask in just a moment how
all of you parsed those remarks by
defense secretary Mounties but first
let's take a look at what NATO has been
up to lately
NATO maneuvers in Poland the exercises
are meant to show that NATO will defend
its eastern member States against any
Russian aggression but how much
protection can Poland Plus Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania actually expect
mixed messages from the White House
presidential candidate Donald Trump said
he supports NATO but also claimed that
the Alliance is obsolete now president
Trump favors better relations with
Russia that does not appear to be good
news for Ukraine where fighting is
flared recently between government
troops and Russian backed separatists
Europe is under increasing pressure to
demonstrate unity
Germany is working to improve strained
relations with Poland earlier this month
Chancellor Merkel met Prime Minister
Beata shoot low in Warsaw to try to
patch things up our president Trump's
policies a wake-up call for Europe
Mathew Carney tunic that report asks how
much US support Eastern European
countries can count on but the fact is
the statement that we heard just before
that from defense secretary mattis he
mentioned the strong support that
doesn't sound like a wholesale rejection
of NATO not at all but this is part of
the problem you have mouth dis coming
over and talking about how NATO is his
second home yes the Europeans should pay
more but the US has been saying that
actually for many years for decades
really but nobody knows you know whom
they should believe now should they
believe Matt is what is Tillerson saying
you've got Flynn out there who's now
gone forced to resign who seemed to take
a somewhat different position and was
cozying up to Moscow
so as this conference gets underway here
in Munich there all of these these open
questions that they're not going to be
able to answer there because what key
question is who's going to replace Flynn
as national security adviser because no
matter how much the the defense
secretary and and the Secretary of
State's support these international
alliances like NATO it really comes down
to the president in the White House what
their position is and that's why the
National Security Advisor is such a key
person in that multi looming defense
secretary mattis does at any rate
appeared to be imposing more concrete
conditions on u.s. participation he is
reported to have told the European
members of NATO that they have until the
end of this year to come up with a plan
for how they are really going to realize
that 2% of GDP target that has actually
been talked about for a long time but
never implemented so the German
government is saying all the right
things now the question is will it
follow through in practice as I said the
targets been out there for a long time
and it hasn't been met the targets the
to 2% target is out there for a long
time it hasn't been met I think Germany
is right now paying 1.2 percent of his
GDP
there are different models now in the
background that will be discussed in
Munich as far as I know there is for
example a the model of saying let's
let's pay 3% of the GDP including
development aid and all these things
because in a wider definition of
security this contributes to a worldwide
security then you can put some
development money and so on and all in
this package to try to to to police that
I think the the main aim of President
Trump is that the Europeans are paying
off that and and I think maybe with some
rights he can he can claim that the big
question is what what role is foreign
policy per se playing into his agenda is
it on the forefront of his agenda NATO
security questions with Russia with
Ukraine with the Prince respect or
wasn't he elected by and large as well
as a kind of isolationist America first
let's repair the infrastructure and
these things so four things and these
things this is his main agenda not
foreign policy I want to come back to
just that point but let me ask you
shimming we just heard Matthew Carney
Jennings say a moment ago that clearly
the defense secretary and the secretary
of state are at pains to try to can to
counteract some of the more
unconventional statements that Donald
Trump has made on the other hand this
very unpredictability does it perhaps
also act as an invitation to rivals and
Rascals like North Korea for example who
then set out to test Donald Trump's
limits sure we see many tests also from
Iran from North Korea from Taiwan and
even foreign from China and a much
weaker pose but the crucial thing from
the point of view of current Chinese
government is what row is the United
States under Trump is going to play
within the NATO is to continue the
leading role but that means determining
strategy and
even until this point is cleared it is
possible to predict what kind of rose or
other partners are going to play if it
is not clarified its if Donald Trump sir
government is just offering some a la
carte services and you you need this
part and you need this part you pay for
that
just like for Japan or Korea then it
isn't another totally in another game to
play play and the first fear of the
Chinese government is a repeating new
Cold War structure that the United
States will holding the leading bro
determine this strategy and all the
European countries because they are too
weak have to follow the United States
then it is a military bloc as we know
from the time of the Cold War the second
fear is that the Asian part of US
strategy could be copied in accordance
to to the new NATO line that means that
Japan for example would take over some
similar part like Germany within the the
NATO structure in in Europe or Great
Britain and the South Korea will play
the part of her friend Australia maybe
in another part Indian is waiting for in
invitation and unless we get a little
bit more clarity about all this point we
will know how the United States how the
administration under Trump is going to
take on the Europe take on the Russia
and take on Russia China so I want to
get to China in just a moment but one
brief question still on the point of
isolationism because indeed that is
Donald Trump's inclination so let's take
a hypothetical case worst case scenario
little green men undercover Russian
inspired agents in the Baltics would the
u.s. put boots on the ground for the
Baltics III think they would and I think
that there's more continuity maybe in
these policies coming out of Washington
now than people realize because if you
remember when Obama came into office
there was great concern in Europe that
there was going to be this pivot to Asia
and Obama was going to be the Pacific
president and so on and then you had the
crisis in Ukraine and you had other
crises smaller incidents in Europe and
the US and the Obama administration were
forced to reorient themselves a bit at
the same time they really relied heavily
on Germany to manage that crisis so I
think that the headline here is that the
US wants to remain engaged in Europe I
don't believe this isolationist rhetoric
I think they want to main remain engaged
but I think that they want Europe to
take care of itself
they trust Europe to take care of itself
precisely because they're more worried
about China right now and they feel that
they really need to spend more resources
there so I think that is what's going on
here unfortunately Trump's tone in the
way that he sort of delivers these
messages you know are often are often
counterproductive quite frankly so in
their circles maybe I can't have that
for very short there are circles in the
Republican Party that are so strictly I
mean they they want NATO to be function
and they would send boots on the ground
and he relies on these circles they're
very foreign policy orientated so let us
now pivot to Asia ourselves mixed
signals on Asia as well even before he
took office President Trump sparked
alarm about whether he meet might reset
America's long-standing one-china policy
in favor of Taiwan and his chief
strategist Steve Bannon has gone so far
as to posit an event inevitable war in
the South China Sea let's take a look
the US and China a show of force in the
South China Sea the region is rich in
natural resources including petroleum
and natural gas and it's home to major
international shipping lanes Beijing
recently began setting up what appear to
be military outposts on coral reefs in
the area to back its territorial claims
Japan and South Korean forces went on
alert last month after Chinese military
vessels sailed too close to their
borders the u.s. is concerned about
China's growing military and economic
power President Trump is accused China
of devaluing its currency and has
threatened to impose significant tariffs
on Chinese imports last month the
president pulled the u.s. out of the
trans-pacific trade agreement known as
TTIP mr. Trump wants to make individual
trade deals with other countries himself
how dangerous are these disputes between
the US and China shimming what is more
likely a shooting war over the South
China Sea a trade war or is it all just
a bunch of hot air I for my part to
suppose that none of this would happen
instead there will be countless
agonizing corals because the Chinese
government is not ready for such a
showdown we see that the Chinese
interpreters encouraged by the
government are now making great offers
to trump
even though old Trump has the clear
China clearly to to the main enemy
Alibaba is offering 1 million jobs
within the next five years within the
United States and other Chinese
companies are rushing to the United
States and say we wiII make your country
great again we we Chinese are making us
agreed again and this provocation
because of Taiwan is not replied very
harshly by China's government Chinese
the spokeman
call it's just a mistake it's not
criminal actors is not a provocation
just a mistake
you should not continue and I think even
in terms with the trade there is there
are some
encouraging China's government supposing
that the the US government is not going
to go that far because the Trump is not
combining China with Japan with Europe
as three partners who are harming United
States but the same means by
manipulating the exchange rate the the
fear of Beijing was that Beijing would
be singled out as the men and so enemy
to be fought against but now the United
States is facing three very strong
trading partners if they treat the one
partner very harsh and the other not it
is not so convincing and the whole
economy is connected much more closely
than Trump could do anything just
separated from other actions ironically
however by virtue of the fact that he
left the trans-pacific trade agreement
Donald Trump if anything has pushed some
of the US allies in the region into the
arms of China and thereby perhaps made
China's position stronger Matthew
Kinnickinnic and I have to ask for you a
brief answer but isn't this the area
where Trump supporters are most
expecting direct action namely on trade
on protectionism absolutely but I think
you know as we just heard it's not going
to be that easy because the interests of
the United States and China are simply
too intertwined so you hear all of this
tough talk coming out of Washington but
it's going to be very hard I think to
produce quick results and the problem is
is that you know in a lot of respects
he's he's right about China he's right
about the trade imbalances with other
parts of the world that the u.s. doesn't
always get the right deal but again as
with Europe and security the problem is
the way he transports this messages and
it often does more damage than he
intends Moulton laning our title coming
back to that America first and whether
it's a threat to world order is it
perhaps the global economic order of
open bear borders of trade of
immigration that is most threatened by
transactions I don't know if it's just
that I think we have to give credit to
the main global
players beside of the United States
Europe China Russia and all of the
leaders right now seem to behave very
cautious very responsible waiting for
real actions not just words
so not jumping to pass to a conclusion
that could could fuel all the tensions
that we're seeing right now thank you
very much thanks to all of you for being
with us today and thanks to you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]